bonjour catherine norris
bonjour à vous me régis son bonjour à
tous les auditeurs et j'adresse un salut
fraternel à tous nos amis guyane est
membre du parti socialiste et soutien à
benoît hamon merci d'être avec nous
catherine néris sans ces périodes
troubles pour votre candidat on va faire
court il dégringole dans les intentions
de vote comment faire à moins de trois
semaines maintenant du vote alors il
faut que les les gens les citoyens
comprennent bien que effectivement nous
sommes à un carrefour où cette élection
ne ressemble à aucune autre
cette vème république l'a peut-être nous
marquer un point d'arrêt pour un
renouvellement à long sur ce non
renouvellement alors effectivement
benoît hamon lui propose des choses qui
n'ont rien à voir avec ce qu' il y a eu
avant pourquoi parce qu'il sait que tous
les outils les mécanismes économiques et
sociaux sont en berne sont en panne et
il faut aujourd'hui actionner le
changement le veut faisons le et ne
marche comme prévu pas un jour presque
sans une mauvaise nouvelle pour lui
on parle du ralliement à manuela
emmanuel macron jean luc mélenchon qui
le double sur sa gauche dans les
intentions de vote il est peu pris dans
la tenaille comme on dit écoutez nous ce
qui nous intéresse c'est pas tant la
gymnastique intellectuelle qui va se
passer entre les médias et les sondages
et c'est ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
communiquer le mieux possible sur le
projet sur le projet sur les
passablement pas simplement il y a le
projet il y a le programme mais il ya
aussi tout ce qu'on peut faire comme
contamination positive par rapport à la
réponse selon nation positive à la
réflexion à ce que nous devons intégrer
si nous voulons passer dans ce nouveau
monde
ce qui faut faire aussi c'est comprendre
que rien ne se fera sans la population
et il faut qu'elle se responsabilise le
rapport à ce qu avec ce revenu universel
les adversaires 10 da que tout
simplement benoît hamon veut donner de
l'argent et oublier cette valeur travail
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça je dis
aussi que ces jeunes de 18 25 ans qui
sont aujourd'hui dans des systèmes moins
je les appelle les orp
c'est à dire à partir du moment où ils
sortent des allocations familiales
classique et qui n'ont pas encore trouvé
de travail parce que la plupart et il
faut le rappeler soit soient apprentis
soient étudiants un même s'il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup trop qui ont décroché
et qui sont sans emploi
je les appelle quand même les orcs tout
et c'est hors tout à un ordre donné
c'est la faute à qui c'est la faute à
peut-être la mise accord de socialisme
avec l'offrant l'armée connaissance
globale du fonctionnement et de
l'appréhension des jeunes d'une certaine
société et je pense que ça tout le monde
a une responsabilité dans cette chose là
maintenant aujourd'hui il y a des
propositions
allons-y les jeunes eux attendent ça on
ne peut plus faire comme si que on leur
dit on va remettre à demain et aux
calendes grecques
oui on va s'occuper de vous et cetera
benoît hamon pourrait faire plus
efficace pour être plus plus constructif
alors qu'il était dans une machine qui
n'a pas vraiment fonctionné pourquoi
pourquoi on devrait croire ans benoît
hamon aujourd'hui à londres ap
rappelons quand même quand il a été
ministre de l'éducation il a fait un
certain nombre de propositions notamment
notamment de remettre en ordre de marche
un certain nombre de personnels qui
avait été quand même supprimé sous
monsieur sarkozy et cette action là elle
a été bénéfique il faut la continuer
parce qu'elle n'est pas suffisante et
c'est ce qu'ils proposent de faire dans
son programme c'est-à-dire réactionnaire
remettre en mouvement
la réinstallation d'un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires pour pouvoir être
contributeurs et contribuer au bon
fonctionnement des institutions
rappelons quand même qu'une nation si
elle veut avoir une démocratie qui
s'expriment c'est dans la stabilité de
ses institutions qu'elle puisse la
trouver un abîme en panne de service
public s'est passé s'oppose une sixième
république donc une modification
profonde de des institutions c'est
partir dans l'aventuré sera encore pas
d'une des institutions d'une
réorganisation institutionnelle qui
devrait permettre effectivement des
socles un peu plus solide
alors quand pour les jeunes quand pour
les grandes personnes quand pour
l'économie solidaire et sociale
rappelons quand même que l'économie
sociale est une n'est pas la moindre
économie n'est pas une sous économie
mais c'est devenu une économie
intermédiaire qui devrait rien su
flairer impulsé l'économie globale et
benoît hamon propose effectivement une
un meilleur une meilleure maîtrise de
cet espace là pour pouvoir fructifier et
réinvestir peut-être les jeunes sur ce
plan nord c'est le vrai candidat de la
gauche benoît hamon c'est le candidat en
tout cas issu de la primaire
ça veut dire qu'en même temps que le
fait qu'il y ait eu une élection
complètement démocratie peut-être
l'assaut vers al hassni n'a pas su le
dire par exemple quand me françois flux
françois fillon de lui dans les affaires
qui livre dans le candidat il est le
candidat de cette primaire de la droite
chez benoît hamon peut-être qu'on n'a
pas entendu assez ça ne s'est pas
s'appuyer là dessus peut-être que les
gens n'ont pas su entendre mais je pense
qu'à partir du moment où il ya eu un
vote démocratique il y a eu une issue
dont sua chine qui l'a pas su faire une
nuit initient des urnes
nul n'est censé ne pas être au courant
alors il faudrait aussi arrêter de
croire que toutes les informations doit
être apportée à domicile et est
mastiquée dans un bruit dans une société
ultra médiatisé ou en mach généralement
tout il y a plus qu'à val une fois qu'on
a mis dans la bouche jeu et
malheureusement ça 2010 est aujourd'hui
je rappelle je rappelle quand même que
et je pense que les tous les citoyens
ont vite s'entendre ça le pouvoir
il est de pouvoir s'exprimer dans une
force de proposition qui est en capacité
aujourd'hui d'être dans une force pour
deux propositions toutes les entités de
contre-pouvoir
moi j'invite quand même les citoyens à
prendre toute leur part y compris dans
toutes les entités qu'eugène cité mais
dans cette élection parce qu'il ne
suffira pas de mettre un gouvernement en
place et un espace législatives il
faudra aussi prendre toute sa part de
responsabilité à la construction de ce
nouvel espace avec benoît hamon et je
l'espère en tout cas que les gens seront
contributeurs de cet espace iv et des
restes j'aurais peut-être dû commencer
par là
aujourd'hui en 2010 tête outre
socialiste ça veut dire quoi exactement
être socialiste ça veut dire se rappeler
tout ce qui a été fait rappelons quand
même que la transformation et la
transition sociale depuis le 19e siècle
a toujours été fait par des socialistes
n'oublions pas cette histoire là aussi
je ne vois aussi dans les propositions
toutes les propositions qui sont faits
et notamment celle de benoît hamon sont
faits pour continuer à contribuer à
cette transformation sociale pourquoi
pour deux raisons d'abord pour répondre
à la souffrance des gens parce que ça
trop souvent on oublie on parle d'eux on
parle de deux choses qu'il faudrait on
parle de beaucoup de matérialisation
cette société on oublie trop souvent que
parce que cette société elle souffre et
parce qu'elle est en souffrance qu'on se
doit d'avoir un regard particulier sur
quoi est ce que ce soit emmanuel macron
par exemple ne peut pas répondre à ses
souffrances de la société mais on ne
répond pas à la souffrance de la société
par des mécanismes d'argent on ne répond
pas la souffrance des gens en leur
faisant miroiter que parce que les
grandes entreprises ont continué à faire
du profit qu'on pourra voir du bien-être
c'est complètement c'est un leurre
par contre quand on dit que peut-être
que quand vous contribuerez et vous
pourrez accéder au pouvoir avec un
pouvoir d'achat en fait du vélo milieu
là vous nous faites du ménage sur quatre
rappelons que mélenchon a été 35 ans au
parti socialiste et que c'est john l'a
peut-être qu'elles ont été initiées par
son parcours et pour son acte de
naissance politique le parti sauf dans
le sud on n'est pas sûr écartés de ces
notions là hein sauf que benoît hamon
les met dans des réformes concrètes par
ce revenu universel par cet
accompagnement de l'apa par cet
accompagnement de l'extension des
retraites par cet accompagnement aux
associations 1 qui vont être concrète et
augmenter dès la première année
alors bien évidemment il ne faudra pas
attendre comme on l'a trop souvent fait
avoir des choses dans l'immédiateté
il faut se rappeler aussi qu'on a
quelques responsabilités c'est pas parce
qu'on veut un truc aujourd'hui est con
souffre aujourd'hui que le médicament
doit fonctionner aujourd'hui il ya le
temps de la maladie ya le temps de la
guérison
peut-être ineris pour l'instant benoît
hamon les nettement dépassé dans les
intentions de vote par jean luc
mélenchon il faut quand même se poser la
question de ce que deviendra le parti
socialiste une fois cette élection
passée vous y pensez vous déjà où la
socialiste convaincu
est ce que le parti socialiste la
question que tout le monde se pose
risque de disparaître
absolument pas le parti national
socialiste a créé des aa connu des
crises bien pire que cela il nous
appartiendra au moment à un moment donné
de réfléchir à comment effectivement
toujours dans un acte participatif à
vouloir participer à cette transition
sociale a nourri l'université d'été du
parti socialiste tout ça ce sont des
lieux des forums d'expression de
réflexion ici en martinique ont connu
une université des morts mais socialiste
n'arrête pas de réfléchir
ils réfléchissent ils construisent et on
voit comment le parti socialiste est
toujours contributeurs et à l'assemblée
nationale et au parlement européen et
dans toutes les entités de
contre-pouvoir quand on est dans
l'opposition
quand nous sommes de pouvoir jeu j'ai
envie de dire et j'appelle quand même
aux consciences que le bilan de françois
hollande n'est pas celui qu'on croit
moi j'invite tous les concitoyens à
faire des comparatifs entre l'avant de
ce qui a été fait pendant ce mandat
peut-être que ce n'a pas été aussi
audible qu'on n'aurait pu l'entendre il
n'empêche qu'il ya eu des choses
extrêmement concrètes qui ont été faites
on le voit sur le déficit on le voit au
niveau économique on ne vaudraient sur
le plan social
allons voir jugeront sur pièce merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin quatre
hérissons rappelle que vous êtes membre
du parti socialiste et soutien à benoît
hamon candidat à la présidentielle merci
bonne journée
[Musique]